all right button hold on we got to hear
about what the [ __ ] babe station is
so babe station was this channel in the
uk right and it would air at like what
like 11
30. yeah yeah something it was literally
just like girls on a couch
like half naked and then they would
occasionally take off their bra but the
whole time
you wouldn't hear anything you would
just hear like porn music but they were
calling someone you could call in and
talk to them
right and there's some good videos on
youtube people trolling them right but
it's really funny but
as like a like a 14 year old i was like
damn
yeah it's basically chatterbaits before
on tv but but you can't hear what
they're saying
yeah because they're talking to someone
oh yeah occasionally they would let you
hear the audio
like yeah yeah this is what you could be
having but also 12 year old me i'm never
going to call them yeah yeah yeah
but oh my god yeah cause i remember
after family guy it would air
so i would like to take a family guy
episode just leave it running you know
yeah
yeah it's just nonchalantly yeah
i noticed actually that like uk tv at
night really
like holds no bards oh that's like porn
on so many channels because i i
because uh aki and i only recently
discovered uh
thanks to matzia about uh the show naked
attraction
um you know wait what's that what's that
yeah you showed that right to me
yeah yeah naked attraction is basically
this this seamless
show it's this show on uk television i
don't know what time it
is it's on channel four about like nine
pm
but basically it's this is this it's
this game show where a guy or a girl
would come onto the show looking for a
boyfriend or a girlfriend
right and in the case with like say a a
boy coming on looking for a girlfriend
yeah what they would do is they would
show five different girls
but they would be butt naked
completely negatively yeah like no
mosaic completely naked and what they
would do is they would start
from the down up so what they would do
is they would first show below the belt
right and then the guy would see
everything you can see
or girl would be like okay i like that
genitalia i don't like that genitalia
yeah
and then and then at that point just
from looking at like the genitalia
they have to be like uh no to this
person and
then they would go up to the tits and
show the face and then they would reveal
the voice
and at the end when there's the last two
people remaining like the last two
contestants remaining
yeah the guy or girl who like originally
came onto the show they have to also
come out naked
oh and then and then as they're naked
they have to pick one of the two and
then they go on a date
it's it's really awful and and i watched
it and aki and i were like
this is the most amazing show i've ever
seen yeah it's called uh
naked attraction naked attraction yeah
and there's clips of it on youtube
yeah this entire how are they getting
wet there's entire seasons of it on
youtube and i don't understand how
they're getting away with it
like we get like i guarantee this
episode is going to get demonstrated
and yet whole episodes of naked
attraction can be on youtube and
youtube's like well i get it's a tv show
so i guess it's okay
yeah but yeah i don't know i thought i
was gonna hate it at first because just
from the concept it sounds absolutely
trashy
but it makes you like the worst person
ever oh you're like oh wow their feet
are slightly disformed i'm gonna have
not even their feet it's like ah their
pussy's a little mangled up
oh god oh my god oh you have to say that
in front of the person i'm like i would
never be able to i don't i don't think i
have the self-confidence no
sure but these are like like just chill
people normal people and they go on and
and
they're just like i just wanted to spice
it up a little bit i'm like this
they're spicing it up and then they're
getting naked in front of the entire
country
there's an inventory i'm like is it
really worth it for the 15 minutes of
fame if you have to show your naked body
yeah they show you a little bit of the
date afterwards and they're always it's
so
awkward it's so awkward it's like hi hi
oh yeah you like it so yeah i i i hear
you how you think about
wins tower defense i mean i like blue
star defense
like how'd you go on a day after you've
just commented on that like weirdly
shaped penis
yeah exactly my favorite though is like
when
they do finally pick a winner right and
it's that awkward hug
oh they do an awkward they do an awkward
hug to the person
but it's so funny how like how how back
both of their like
things are so that they genitally
doesn't touch as they hug each other
and the host is just watching and it's
like all right she's a christmas host in
the uk it's what's that woman she does
all the channel 4 shows
uh you she's a big brother oh davina
mccool yeah davina mccoy yeah yeah
so and she's a really big name in the uk
i think she's a good host
it's kind of yeah that you know kind of
got relegated to the sea team
i didn't know i didn't know she did big
brother but now i know that that totally
makes sense